something to happens to you when you
leave this town far the way the hazy ER
it all gets with me and I've left I
remember all of it
[Music]
this movie kind of scared the crap out
of me and also made me laugh like all
put together and I think that's kind of
Stephen King so I'm gonna ask you guys
first what's your favorite Stephen King
adaptation or just book by itself misery
misery I think the scariest book is is
Pet Sematary because you really get into
the emotion of what they're feeling and
the grief of what they're feeling but I
just I love misery look Booker both I
mean Kathy Bates and Oh heartbreaking
also misery Chastain and when I was
reading the book that's amazing right so
before I was reading the book I was like
oh my gosh someone else has the names
yes good I was imagining myself like oh
no she's not misery Chastain the heroine
from his books and then that's why she
kept saying you can't kill misery
Chastain thank goodness for that misery
is a big one for me too I love the
adaptations stand by me hmm of course I
also love Stephen King's on writing
which is his kind of personal book about
how he brings all this to life yeah it's
really interesting because I feel like
so many scenes from the book are so like
burned in people's brains like by the
time we get to the the movie you kind of
have to go crazy and like one of the
scenes is the grandmother scene I will
go ahead say yeah so talk about that
scene cuz like it lit up the internet
the minute the trailer landed and
everyone just kept talking about hashtag
naked grandma
I was shocked actually when I saw the
first trailer I was like wow they are
putting the scene that front they're
like doing it like no spoiler alert its
spoilers but that woman who's her name
the actress she was so credible she was
just amazing and she was like up for
anything and he was directing us and he
would throw stuff out and be that freeze
so I be reacting to her going I think
that me good now go like he was he was
really the conductor when I first saw
that trailer I was like for sure that's
an edit was she freezing no but then you
know you guys told me that it's it's all
in the performance you can see her
breathe a little bit
I think she's freezing real quick I have
to say the blood scene did you get like
a chance to do that together like how
did y'all pair that up between the blood
we did actually I mean I just shot the
blood take section way early when we
first started shooting and then though I
was there though I was hovering yeah
yeah you came yeah it was such a full-on
thing - yeah I have to do to make sure
that she came out of life was that the
scariest thing to film like what was the
scariest thing to either film or watch
from these films like if you can pick
like a moment that was either like scary
filming it or maybe just watching it on
screen I mean it was scary to watch her
do that scene because this blood was
rushing in and it was this tight space
so it was really Jessica on her own you
know yeah so if anything happened it
would be a tough one to get you well
yeah there wasn't there was no really
visibility so every time I submerged cuz
it was quite deep I did have that
feeling of like if something happens you
know no one's gonna really know where I
am in this tank
wow that was a bit scary well you played
on-screen very well
the losers Club is officially but God
first of all the guys what was the movie
that scared you as a kid because I have
a feeling that whatever you got scared
first as a kid that's what's gonna scare
you forever oh Anthony Hopkins in magic
oh yeah magic oh yeah yeah Exorcist
freaking yeah Fright Night their
original Fright Night there was a scene
in the original Fright Night that scared
me a lot and then the first Evil Dead
movie and then I know it's it's a famous
one but really the Anthony Perkins is
coming down the stairs at the end of
psycho dressed as oh my oh yeah yeah
yeah that's where that really scared me
this we're gonna the end of psycho isn't
that weird I just told you it was a
Night of the Living Dead and and I and I
just remembered earlier with the Wizard
of Oz is actually strangely terrifying
when I when I was a kid my first saw is
like yeah so you guys all got to see the
first movie before you got cast and so
did it scare you were you scared in any
of them or any of the scenes in this one
where you're saying yourself like it's
kind of terrifying because that ending
scene scared the crap out of me I like
the scene where he's down in the
basement the first film where he goes
down sideways and just kind of slowly
pulls back out of them yeah I like then
the first film came out the refrigerator
and then when we got to oh yeah we got
to reprise it in this one I got really
excited when I we came on set and there
the refrigerator was there because I
really liked that theme I don't really
get scared of that type of stuff I like
that now is like an adult more like just
telling yesterday like Japanese horror
really scares me
yeah like audition audition that was the
actually movie I've ever seen people
which one a few movies I think people
pass out it yeah that was that's the
type of stuff where I'm like I can't
deal with this I'm like French does that
too like Rob vegetarian saw that movie
Oh Roz off is real good
ya know Roz really cool you guys check
it out um anyone from you like that you
particularly remember like scaring the
crap out of you from this valve for the
first one or this one or this one um
yeah actually you know what's funny
about that moment when in the first one
when they even he pulls back in his eyes
yeah it was actually that was kind of
that was also unsettling oh but I just
loved the first movie also for the exact
opposite of the horror which I actually
felt like the nostalgia and like the
very like stand by me
kind of like innocence there was wait a
second is Robin or they have accidents
and they they caused act or Road yeah
so the job of the Hutt so first of all
did you guys get to like are you
improvising all of it is it all written
because the job of the Hutt
impersonation I have to feel like either
Andy wrote that for you you just wanted
to do it I think I just did it and then
I also did another we did a lot of other
stuff we did Andre the Giant yeah yeah
that was funny
you want to give me what Stefan was say
for Darius hottest night well
[Laughter]
if it isn't dead
if it ever comes back
we'll come back to you we didn't stop it
so you guys like I heard from the other
kid Sheldon get your car from the
previous film I heard you guys were
gonna get a cure huh yeah no car was go
yeah nope right I kind of forgot y'all
mad about yeah yes I got a license for
that purpose you got yes they can get
your getting mine in November hopefully
your carthon's never gonna try your GERD
you get your did you get here is my
permit I don't have my license yet only
I felt my permit test twice
really oh yeah well you can do it again
that's y'all did again you can get as
many times as you well if you guys
another then you can talk about that
because like from the first one to this
one you guys have done so much I mean
you guys have like a whole bunch of
stuff going on and stranger things and
like all these different projects so
when y'all got back together what was it
like did you all have to catch up on
everything you were doing no wait we're
talking basically talk every day oh my
gosh
just like into us being in person again
just reconfirming that finn is now
taller than me it's weird right every
time we come back I used to be the
tallest sketch it was so weird and now I
was like bro
I look up to them well you those
different spurts and Sofia's gonna be
the tallest one day you know crazy real
quickly though I was gonna ask you guys
since this is a film about like being
scared and was there anything in the
first one or even this one that like
terrified you specifically tell her
nothing terrified us okay fear of just
us being separated forever and ever I
think the one thing that actually scared
me it didn't scare me when we shot it
cuz I wasn't in the scene but when
anywise comes out the water and they had
the effect on him like where he's like
yeah that's integrating that actually
was really scary I never saw it we saw
the Gators what's it like working with
Bill is he's great he's like the chiller
son sighs well I should say bill
skarsgård yeah yeah he is the chillest
the chills as he can be a pepper except
for sorry except for before it take when
he yeah goes getting in character he's
like like it's scary like you feel like
you're gonna get that's a scary single
you feel like you're gonna die
the last thing I guess I'll ask you guys
is there a specific Stephen King
adaptation that you particularly love
well The Shining is a classic you know
five or so and they're in the 70s most
amazing Green Mile is amazing they're
good many ever good best and my gosh any
good stay by me stay by me
first question guys on the first I heard
you guys were supposed to get a car if
the film was certified fresh or made a
certain number at the box office
I burned my car right II was true you
Jesus was gonna give us a car right yeah
the predinner was gonna give us a cart
oh you didn't get your car no hope oh my
gosh I totally forgot what I mean look
at so y'all talking about that like
words right where's your car
yeah where's my car you just for a
bigger car yeah a 2090 calm it's like a
hard room now you gotta get a Tesla like
get the top-line Tesla oh yeah be my
other thing duck horn carburetor and
stuff oh you guys have done a lot since
I'm the first one filmed I mean sharp
objects and you got the lodge coming out
of knives out and are you free the dark
witch exam of course everybody's doing a
ton of stuff yeah so what was it like
getting back together did y'all like do
like a quick like recap like I did this
like what was it they all know yeah
we're all we got I've spent too much
time together in between you had the
first one the second one and we yeah we
talked a lot yeah when so we were always
always pretty we're always pretty
updated on on each other so are you in
that hey yeah
is it out yeah okay so when you guys
watch the first one or if you've seen
the second one what was the scariest
moment for you either in the first one
or in this coming one Oh
the first one was not well cuz we spent
so much time making a movie we were
completely numb to everything but I
guess yeah the second one will probably
be different we haven't seen any it's
gonna be scary the next lesson we did
the experience yeah this one made the
whole experience
we did we did the haunted house thingy
yeah that's scary
yeah that was fun I did it too and I was
I was very scared it's fun that um so
they made you guys a little younger in
this one like I said I'm skeptical
promoting
I'm skeptical that it means that I will
sound good
really because I could when I try it I
felt so bad when I'm like one way
they're like doing Jackie shouldn't that
your voice I really I know I am I know I
know said to do a TRL it's definitely
God I didn't I felt bad I'm not your
voice was so high during the first
minute yeah yeah I know the first week
my voice was like out of the chipmunks
Jeremy my I'm always like dropped
I mean even ADR for the first one that's
good they're like they cut it in between
lines and it was like there is nothing
missing
Johnson's are pregnant like it was
really bad so I'm curious to see yeah my
I haven't changed physically my voice
changed a little bit though I naturally
have a deep voice
so especially even in the first it why
okay so so I didn't have to change much
but I did have to do ATR to make my
voice sound higher so with Bill
skarsgård on this one did you guys like
bond because I know what like on the
first one like Andy coming kept y'all
separated a little bit were y'all able
to like hang out with them and your
older counterparts a little bit more a
little bit we did the speed-dating thing
with all of them Oh tell me about the
speed-dating so we just basically I
think all the young the young loser sat
down and we had we each had a table at a
restaurant and there they kept the
adults kept switching I don't remember
to either I remember to just like just
like once and then just lies I think
okay so real quick give me one of the
questions you asked or one of the
answers like give me something that you
asked during speed-dating PJ redstone
told me that the Rolling Stones were a
boy band boy stones are a boy band
they're not even that good
Wow that's shots fired shots fired
um I don't remember like what we asked I
feel like we just had like a good
conversation everybody but like Jay Ryan
has been through some like krei
stop I won't that's best for later but
like he's been through like so much
stuff guy has a lot on rebuild yeah
honest build if you know what I mean
that that's a good let's be honest
that's really great like model and y'all
look the same like I feel like you're I
say like it's insane so yeah cute
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
Andy first of all congratulations on the
film I loved it that's like a thing yeah
but I really want to start with the fact
that like that naked granny scene like
let's just say it like that scene from
like y'all put it in the trailer and
like put it out there but then you see
it in the movie and you're like oh my
gosh yeah yeah it's pretty intense yeah
yeah it all has to do with them
predictability you know and the way we
shot that I I'm pretty experimental when
it comes to like like those kinds of
kick up scares where the fear comes from
an unnatural movement or in the back or
if a silhouette that moves in a weird
way I've been doing that for a long time
even the mom I you can see that I'm like
in the backstage I'm like puppeteer and
the actors with with ropes and and
strings
I didn't puppeteer the actress Joan
Gregson and this one she did by herself
but I did do I did ask her to walk back
and forth so there's a reverse reverse
action where she walks back and forth
and she's completely naked it was a
closed set so nobody actually saw it
except for me
but she's phenomenal she's incredible
she was game for everything she
understood the you know the tone of
humor and horror in the scene which is a
you know a very weird balance yeah and I
would say that that's like in everything
from the adults like it first of all
just casting these new adults because
just the casting set the internet on
fire when you announce those names and
people were doing fan edit drawings like
people are going nuts so I was excited
to you know I was on fire too when
finally you know I started to get all
the actors that I wanted them in the
movie so I was like like backflipping so
how did it how did you how did you go
about selecting them were you just like
okay these were my four from the
beginning and you just knew in my mind
of course I wanted to to
you to create a caste that that had like
physical similarities to their to the
kids so that was a probably already but
then like you know okay I want to work
with my favorite actors in the industry
and Jessica was one of them
james mcavoy incredible Bill Hader is a
funniest guy on earth and also he's like
capable of doing the incredible dramatic
work yeah I would say like he definitely
has a lot of hero moments in this and a
lot of humor and he said that like some
of it was him but like you wrote a lot
of that for him talk about that well
things like really grew you know on the
set on said sometimes you know it's a
it's a living organism like a movie it's
not that you write a script and then you
should what is what's on the pages and
it's one of the one of the you know
probably most valuable learnings as a
director that I'm still on that that
curve that is like you know this is
ongoing and it's ever-growing creative
process and you have to you have to draw
from yourself but also from your work
with the actors and sometimes you know
the dialogue just the you know the
brainstorming on a scene or the scene
itself like makes it like takes it to
another level and with all the actors
happen but with Bill you know because
he's just such a comical genius that
that was probably a little magnified all
right there are a few me real quick
what's your favorite Stephen King
adaptation besides your own it's it you
know the Shawshank Redemption is a movie
that I love a lot
that's a good one yeah
you